for more on this i want to bring in
caitlyn jenner because i want to get
your thoughts on what's unfolding well
now we'll be hearing lots more from
caitlyn jenner because the former
olympian has landed herself a new job at
fox news things are going well the news
outlet announced on thursday that
caitlyn's joining their team as a
contributor fox news media ceo suzanne
scott thinks she'll be a perfect fit on
the team and sharing in a statement
quote kaitlyn's story is an inspiration
to us all she is a trailblazer in the
lgbtq plus community and her illustrious
career spans a variety of fields that
will be a tremendous asset for our
audience her first official appearance
on thursday's hannity a show she's
appeared on in the past first of all i
got a gift thank you what is it i know i
love kids to the face mask thing out
here in california so i thought i would
get you one hannity supports caitlyn
he's not allowed to he's on the news as
for how caitlin feels well the 72 year
old tv personality shared her excitement
on instagram writing quote i am humbled
by this unique opportunity to speak
directly to fox news's millions of
viewers about a range of issues that are
important to the american people
it's been great and kate's new gig
should come as no surprise as an
outspoken conservative she's been a fox
news guest many times right now we have
an epidemic of crime in this state my
problem that i have here is with the
ncaa really going all the way up to
the olympic committee i support joe
rogan i like his show he speaks his own
mind
this used to be a free speech country
before we got into this council culture
she's so invested in politics that she
even threw her hat into the california
governor race last year boy the ball
started rolling really fast
we are like becoming officially
a campaign with
oh my goodness
for california
though her run was unsuccessful and i
was able to assemble a great team great
group of people
and
i have to thank all of them thanks to
caitlyn's new gig she'll be back on
television discussing the issues most
important to her but there's one place
you definitely won't see her on her
famous family's new hulu reality series
the kardashians i am very excited to
have another baby two of my daughters
are being considered for the cover of
american vote i probably would have
murdered kendall myself that was between
the two of us of course caitlyn appeared
in most seasons of the fam's first
series keeping up with the kardashians
are you going over
in a minute i'm gonna go
use the ladies room need any help sure
come on jenner
this is a first let's go but there's no
hard feelings earlier this month the
reality star tweeted i was there when
this started from day one i watched it
grow and doing the show for almost 20
seasons was one of the highlights of my
life to be able to work with my family
for all those years connect with fans it
was incredible happy that it continues
for my family it's been the most amazing
year and for now caitlin has a lot on
her plate not only her new tv gig but
she also recently welcomed her 20th
grandchild and she says keep them coming
yesterday i actually got a little
picture in there on my 20th grandchild
it is just it's amazing you know i have
10 kids
um now we're up to 20 grandchildren
yes um
a little goldie
goldie a brooklyn jenner
came into the world just this week kylie
had hers just a month ago
so we're up to 20. i tell the girls i'm
going for 30.
i love i love a good number and i think
30s you know pretty good yeah
[Music]
you